Todd McShea back here on the Rich Eisen
show fresh off of what we all witnessed
last night that was something else how
Todd that was crazy
it really was I was out at the Rose Bowl
last week and that was probably the best
game that I've been to live since the
Vince Young that line or battle that
they had and and then I don't I wouldn't
say the national championship was as
good a game as one of those epics in
terms of four quarters of really good
play but it was just such a crazy turn
of events from the first half of the
second half I mean who how many other
coaches in the world would pull their
quarterback who's twenty five and two
and in favor of a true freshman in the
second half of a national championship
game and and it just it turns out to be
the right move just it was an amazing
finish and then to go back and forth
with two true freshman quarterbacks
really playing well making one mistake
here there but for the most part playing
at a really high level so do you think
the idea putting two in there had
anything to do with the rumor that he
was going to transfer no and get in
there no I really don't I really I just
don't I don't see Nick Saban caring
about not that he would wouldn't care
about him leaving but I just think Nick
Saban so focused on one goal the next
game you know the Belichick saving way
and I think he's not gonna let an 18
year old hold him hostage I think that
basically yeah he may have sensed it but
I don't think he's going to make a
decision off of that I think
realistically and it was obvious and you
know there was rumors of it
even before the semi final game that
they were against Clemson that they were
going to potentially go and go to and
the if things weren't going well and
they just got out to a lead the defense
was playing so well they didn't need to
try it but to it from everything I've
heard was just lights out in practice
you push them in the in the spring and
hurts just was struggling so much that
they had to do something they had to
find a way to throw the ball and two
became in it's like the whole game
changed the energy for Bama changed all
of a sudden the defense was playing at
an even higher level it just was a
perfect time to pull that move in and
really it was what
had to happen from a football standpoint
and it lit a spark to Todd McShea here
on the Rich Eisen show how many Pro
prospects were on that field last night
I think up to 23 24 you know maybe 10 of
them are underclassmen so will who think
that the January 15th coming up that's
the declaration date I think a lot of
them will probably wind up leaving but
um but you know make a fitzpatrick the
safety didn't have a massive impact game
he was battling some some injury stuff
but he's got a chance to be a top ten
pick Calvin Ridley who who really stole
that ball
there's no way to was throwing that ball
the game tire mmm he was throwing a
number 22 the nagi to Paris the running
back but but Calvin kept working back to
the ball as it usually does and uh made
to play and tied the game up but
Ridley's I think maybe the only first
round wide receiver that truly belongs
in the first round in a bunch of guys on
the defensive side and then for Georgia
those two backs have a chance to go in
the first two rounds and while Chuck was
the it was the bell cow and got more of
the carries I think you're gonna wind up
seeing Soni Michelle go higher and then
potentially maybe late first round I
think after Seco and Berkeley there's a
whole lot of really good running backs
maybe no true first rounder but um but I
think he's in that second tier that
makes for the next 3-4 guys like Darius
guys from LSU and so on and so forth I
think he's gonna be right there
infection yeah we're gonna see them on
the first Friday of March at the combine
that's when the running backs get out
there Todd McShea joining me here when
you mention all of the pro prospects are
you including twenty twenty first
overall selection to a Tongo vile oh are
you including him in that mix no no no
these are just the draft eligibles not
there yet well I mean he won't be the
first overall pick in 2020 unless he's
the running mate of Oprah and 2020 last
night Todd mature are you kidding me oh
so then what I saw on Sunday night
absolutely Todd now I know
it doesn't look all that big I'm not
gonna get into this now yeah you did
so so who is who is the number one
quarterback on your draft board as we're
sitting here right now it's really close
between Sam Donald and Josh Rosen I
ultimately if I had to win a game today
in the NFL it would be with Josh Rosen I
think the guy I want to go to battle
with for the next 10 years is Sam
Donnell and we've done a lot more to
unearth and a lot more digging to do I
just you know the just be straight with
you the reports you get from guys who
have been on the scouting trail and the
digging deep and from people inside the
said UCLA's building that Josh Rosen can
be difficult at times questions
authority at times you know this and
like everyone's talked about this he
loved the game does he need the game
those sorts of things
which you can't brush off they were
hugely important but then you put on the
tape especially the USC UCLA game it's
apples to apples he's just watching them
go back and forth and very clearly Josh
Rosen is more NFL ready today more
polished goes through progressions he
trusts his protection more than Donald
did this past year for obvious reasons
because he was getting killed you know
two out of every three times he dropped
back but uh dartle got into some bad
habits but in my opinion they're mostly
curable I think he's just got to learn
to get two hands on the ball protect the
ball he really had good pocket presence
when he trusted his offensive line two
years ago and I my assumption is he will
he'll revert back to that and continue
to progress in that area and when it's
all said and done I just think he can
create more extend more plays and I
think his leadership and it's the way
that guys around him believe in him and
follow him I think are really important
and at that position and and Rosen the
questions have to be answered between
now and the draft well how do you answer
those Todd because I mean you are you
are one of many of who I respect
whoare I'm thrilled through my network
or this show I get to talk to right
around this time of year huh
that keeps saying Rosen is not I'm just
flat-out intimating that the scouts
believe he's the you don't want him in
your foxhole he's he comes from a rich
family so he doesn't need football and
he comes out and he calls out the NCAA
for being what they are which are
hypocrites
so so why is that a bad mix for a guy
where the skill set like is to be the
number one overall pick of the draft
this is why you have to did enrich this
is really like that's the process now
because yeah you have to trust your
sources and that the people I've talked
to I certainly trust but they're all
also area scouts who've been out on the
road you know missing their kids and
their their families and they get ornery
this time of year
Loden and I just I want to make sure you
know I met with him and in talking to
him I actually I liked them I thought he
was personable and I don't mind the
n-c-double-a stuff know what he was
right everything he said was right just
about everything he said was right right
and so I understand that stuff it's am I
going to get a full focus out of him
because outside a Roethlisberger I'm
just about every quarterback that you
would put in that top tier is an
absolute crazed lunatic and has been
since day one and Roethlisberger's come
a long way but just obsessive about the
preparation the work the love of the
game and just need it you know from
rogers to brady to the Mannings it's the
breeze etc and so if I'm looking to get
an elite quarterback which is what I'm
doing with the first or second pick in
the draft
then I want to make sure that he has
those qualities because history tells me
that ones that don't usually end up
busting and so I that's why it's so
important but I also I you know got a
dig deeper get some of the psychological
reports back we're GM's get involved and
the college coordinators get more
involved in the process and more
interviews I think we'll learn more
listen I don't mind if he has a little
bit of jerk to them if you will I
you know these guys are can be very
difficult to deal with sometimes that's
fine but is it going to be he's not
coachable is question authority you know
it's fine if you're you're tough to be
around but you don't want to draft Jay
Cutler and I get a lot of Jay Cutler
type reports back last one for you Todd
do you have as much man love for say
Kwan as I do and all the other Talent
evaluators I've talking to about yeah
it's tough not to rich it really is I
mean he's special
yeah and usually I don't believe in
drafting and running back in the first
round got to kind of be exception to the
rule Adrian Peterson clearly was we went
for a while there without one and my
opinion and recently we've had a few
from Todd Gurley to GT Elliott for now
yeah Leonard fournette last year and
even Christian McCaffrey in a different
poll but but I think that he is the only
one in this class and it's a really deep
class of running backs to mainland
brakes love could be a second third
round pick out of Stanford that's how
deep it is with Darius guys from LSU and
Ronald Jones from from USC the to USC I
mean the two were Georgia running backs
there was only the two alabama running
backs of me there you're talking about
10-12 guys in that second third round
ranged along there but I think that
Berkeley is the only one where if you're
gonna use a first-round pick on a
running back he belongs in that
exception to the rule category great job
on the on the road for use this season
Todd really enjoyed your coverage on the
sidelines and whatever you did and and
when you're out here for pro days or
what have you please come in studio love
to have you here in person we USC and
UCLA will get together on their pro days
and we can make it into it yeah sounds
good I'm sure Chip Kelly will make that
happen for us topic sure the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience